The young dudes are not at all deterred by the gray hair.
They see it as a little tinsel,
too little sparkle and shine.
The girls that get it, get it.
And not only do the girls that get it get that part,
they also understand, and I think you would agree with me,
it's called a MILF because it's a mom I'd like to fuck.
The young dudes are not at all deterred by the gray hair.
They see it as a little tinsel,
too little sparkle and shine.
There's just so many little, like,
urban myths about women and their looks and what men's desires are.
And it's really all just designed to cause separation between us
and then fighting in between the women.
I remember being a young girl and thinking,
what the fuck would he want with that old lady?
Look at her fucking gray hair.
Now that I'm one of those old ladies at 41
and I have a little bit of gray hair,
I don't know what the fuck it does to these 20 something college boys
that are just.
Just don't believe the lies that men say
to cause the arguing and in fighting.
Because the girls that get it, get it.